hi everyone I'm David I'm the co-founder
and CEO of hunch it's a data tool to
bridge the gap between data analysts and
business users
so does anyone know who said this a
basic problem about anybody of data is
to make it
more easily and effectively handleable
by mines any ideas
close actually he did know him
John tukey said this the mathematician
statistician probably none of us would
be here if it wasn't for him and he said
it almost 50 years ago
and of course you know a lot of time has
passed since then and I don't think
anyone would say that this problem has
been solved and you know it's perhaps it
can never be fully solved but the
question that we're interested in is it
is is it possible to do better than
today's tools is it possible to make it
easier to make sense of data
all right so I became really interested
in this topic when I was working as a
Management Consultant and analyst I read
the works of two people Edward tufty who
wrote about how powerful data
visualizations can be in helping you to
make sense of the world and John Boyd
the originator of the ooda loop
um the fighter pilots and you know
military strategists who showed that
rapidly making sense of the world is
literally the key step in this Loop of
survival it helps any organism survive
and thrive in a dynamic world and that
describes all of us and all of the
organizations that that we work with so
I worked
it's interesting
so I worked uh with uh I I I I
co-founded a startup called Cape
networks a few years later and
um we put some of those ideas into
practice so we built software that
helped Network
administrators many of whom were not
experts make sense of complex networking
data really quickly and in the process
of doing that we learned a lot about how
to how to make it really you know a lot
of data really interactive and really
performant but what's kind of ironic is
that we had a whole lot of our own data
a whole lot of sales data operational
data Finance data and we faced even
though we were building a data sense
making tool ourselves we faced a lot of
the same challenges that data teams face
everywhere in in making sense of their
their data so after Aruba Networks which
is Cisco has been competitor acquired
Cape to be face of their software
portfolio
my co-founders and I decided to take
what we'd learned and apply it to more
data more business data
and so we founded hunch which is a
shared canvas for both data analysts and
business users to to collaborate to work
together to make sense of data it's
really visual it's spatial it's fast and
I I want to share some of our learnings
today so just a couple things to bear in
mind until about two weeks ago we were
just three people
we don't have a product with
pre-products so I'm not trying to sell
you anything but we've spoken to a lot
of early users and has some great
feedback
I don't know why these images aren't
showing a lot of great feedback from
from from from a lot of people we're
really grateful for and I I really want
to show share some of that some of those
learnings with you
now before we do that before we kind of
go into the learnings and the the the
the the demo that's that as Scott
mentioned is I want to start with why
why is this a difficult problem to work
on
why should we try anyway and why we
think that latency is a really important
part about the problem and the solution
all right
so why is this hard so the existing
tools out there SQL bi interfaces if you
think about you know Tableau or
spreadsheets like Excel have been
largely unchanged and used by millions
of people hundreds of millions of people
in some cases for the last
20 to 30 years so they've really stood
the test of time
so it's a big question is it even
possible to build something that is
sufficiently better
and if we do
it has to be better for two very
different sets of people both analysts
and business users and they're very
different needs very different skill
levels so that's also extremely
difficult in and of itself and then
third is once you have you know
potential designs or hypotheses about
what could potentially work
it's not sufficient just to make a few
mock-ups and to show people ask them
what they think you have to actually the
only way to validate that that is to to
try it out to feel what that software
feels like with a very diverse set of
data so you know what happens if you've
got data sets with lots and lots of
columns or with lots and lots of rows or
very few or you know Fields with very
high cardinality or low cardinality all
the different data types all the
combinations of those things and what
you start realizing is that building an
MVP
there's not that much that's M about it
to make it viable it really isn't
minimal you it's so it's extremely high
bar to actually test out your hypotheses
and designs
and then
you know you're making something new and
novel but making it really performant
and as you know as I mentioned before
latency is a big part of what we're what
we're trying to address but making
things that are both novel and
performance is extremely hard and there
are tons of technical challenges there's
uh there's trade-offs that you have to
make uh both you know technically as
well as how you work the kinds of people
and skills that they need to to work on
the on on the project and lastly there's
more than 50 years of of history in the
space hundreds uh if not thousands of
successes and failures to learn from
there's tons and tons of research more
and more of the last 10 years or so and
there's so many other people working on
this in the space on this on this
problem so how do you learn from what
other people have done
and still approach the problem with The
Beginner's mind
so
to do this you need to be able to build
a better data experience and you have to
be crazy enough to try to build a data
experience and we're definitely
somewhere in in on the right hand side
all right so why Try
this is a slightly different version of
the mat Turk
image that has been shown a hundred
times of on the last a couple days but
because there are so many different
players because the market is crowded
it's a it's a hint that there's a real
problem there and there isn't one
dominant solution that is so much better
than everyone else
and all of those
products all of those companies were
built
in a slightly different time they've
been so many things that have happened
in the last couple years that really
change
what is feasible and really some of the
requirements for for you know a really
great data experience so for example
uh you know the changes in the last
couple couple years with data now we
increasingly have all of our data and
metadata in one place with a modern data
stack the semantic layer we also have
very different behaviors and
expectations in in in in in our work in
addition to just more data maturity in
our organizations we're now used to very
collaborative multiplayer SAS tools
whether it's canva figma notion Etc and
it really feels like they're you know
it's time for a modern collaborative
data tool and lastly and I think
actually the most most importantly we
obviously been talking a lot about llms
and their potential during the last few
days but in addition to that it is now
possible to have really really fast
queries really which enable really fast
interactions with with data with you
know technology like click us and and
duckdb
so
speaking about speed
I want to talk a little bit about
latency
this is a really simplified model of how
we make sense of the world so we ask
questions
we learn something based on the answer
to those questions
that enables us to ask better questions
and to learn even more useful things get
better insights and better questions and
so on and anything that gets
in between these two activities is a
problem
so any latency or friction and this this
this latency operating in two very
different levels when it comes to
interacting with data one is that the
organizational level where you have you
know as a business user you're asking a
question that question is then
you know put in a ticket and prioritize
and put on a queue to for someone to
eventually analyze it and come back to
you so then you ask more questions and
and so forth so that's a sort of
organizational latency and then the
second is a product interaction level
where you're actually sitting in front
of a product either as the analyst or
the the business user analyzing the sort
of results and you're you have you're
curious about something or you're trying
to figure out some something and then
you have to wait for queries to execute
and fill a response response time
so let me just go back here
so for the for organizational latency
you have really long lead times really
slow iterations and that really limits
the number of useful questions and
insights and decisions that that you can
make as an organization and in our
product latency level we could talk a
lot we could spend a lot of time talking
about this and the next few slides but
I'm going to try and move through them
quite quickly is that there's a lot of
research that shows that even modest
amounts of additional latency in
software dramatically changes user
Behavior there seems to be a break point
at around 300 to 500 milliseconds where
productivity really has a step change
um where people become significantly
less productive
and and and and this is you know both
like back in the kind of Mainframe days
with with search with Commerce but even
with uh with data so
um Liu and Jeffrey here showed that even
with just a 500 milliseconds delay it
significantly decreased usage for visual
analysis and changed how people explored
data
so what are the potential solutions to
this if we especially if we limit the
you know the scope of this to to to data
tools to to the software that we use
in in short it's really creating a
shared space
to reduce organizational latency a space
that more and more people can can work
in and
um and and and and can and work more
effectively together in and to make all
of their interactions with that tool
much more productive
now there's there's a we can break this
down and continue breaking this down and
this is by no means mutually exclusive
and collectively exhaustive but I think
that there's some really useful things
here and at least in the way that we
think about how to solve this problem so
firstly in the sort of shared space
making it easy to learn we need to build
on what's familiar people are familiar
with SQL and sheets but for everything
else interactions that are unfamiliar we
need to flatten that learning curve as
much as possible make it really sort of
rest on as few new Concepts and
interactions as we can
and make as many of those interactions
really direct so you don't have to learn
them in order to start using the
software
and then to make it more collaborative
you can make software collaborative both
synchronously sort of multiplayer
fashion or asynchronously and and take
more advantage of the social dimension
of working with data so we all it's very
useful to know what is the VP of sales
looking at or what is the data analyst
on my team looking at and use that as
the way to find relative uh relevant
information and uh and and and to work
together
and then in terms of making each
interaction more productive
we want to keep people in a flow State
and that is
that requires more than just what we're
showing here but but two of the key
pieces is is one is making interactions
very fluid so you can fluidly go from
exploration and exploratory work to to
creating assets to explaining what
you're doing and back again and also
making each interaction really low
latency
and then then making every interaction
high bandwidth as well so we're you know
we are visual creatures we're pattern
matching machines we don't take enough
advantage of that in in our software
typically uh and and and also we are
that we think very spatially organisms
developed brains in order to navigate
through space so space is and spatial
thinking is the sort of most fundamental
level
so
you know how did we go from kind of
these guiding principles these ideas
about how to improve interactions to
actually building a product or and and
trying out different approaches
so first thing we did
so those are my co-founders Ross and
Alex I'm based in San Francisco they're
based in in Cape Town and we we've been
working together since Ross nice since
high school Alex you know and and and
and and Ross and I were at Cape together
as well well we took 10 days we went to
to France together we locked ourselves
in an Airbnb away from our kids and all
every other distraction and and we we
covered the walls with every idea that
we that we had about how to solve this
how you know what what you know if we
were really dreaming what what would be
the the the you know the best things
that we could that we could imagine
and we came up with a couple of
different options and and and you know
we we prioritized one particular
approach we went we went back
to our our families and we got building
Ross and Alex
um uh although other coders I was
working on a design and also going back
to some of the the sacred texts that is
John tukey's
um exploratory data analysis that's the
book where that the quote from the
beginning of this talk was from
uh and within uh within about a month
and a half we had our first prototype
and I'm going to step through it here
hopefully the the images uh in its sort
of uh Play Ball but basically the way
that this worked is that for any data
set that you're looking at in a table
any query result every field
was shown in a long list down the side
in a single Lane and it depending on the
data type it was expressed as a a
frequency distribution chart or a Time
series chart or or bar chart for the
different data types
and you could sort of scroll down and
see see more
let me just
I'm not sure why this is not
cooperating
yeah all right so we're gonna we're
gonna push through we're gonna we're
gonna try and get through this yeah so
what then what you can do is to kind of
explore the the data that you have is
grab any field
and drag it into a lane another Lane so
in this case we have shipping date
so we move so that allows us to see
sales by shipping date quantity by
shipping date and every single other
field by shipping date so we didn't
didn't matter if it's a measure or that
Dimension you just combine the data to
to explore it and likewise there with
you can see the product subcategory as a
as a new Lane so you can see can you see
you can see that too and it's a you know
very very quick way of is exploring
every you know different relations
potential relationships in your data and
you could then highlight you can click
to highlight any piece of data on in on
on on this on the screen so in this case
we click to highlight phones and then
that enabled you to see sort of phone
sales by ship dates or you know phone
the distribution of phone quantities
phone discounts Etc
and then you could grab any one of these
charts and add it to a story to go from
the kind of exploratory analysis to
explanatory analysis and that story can
be shared with your organization
now the challenge
if you haven't already
seen it is that this is quite hard for
especially if you're not really kind of
data literate to make sense of and to
and to follow along with and it gets
extremely hard as you add more and more
different uh different fields
so we
we took some of the the learnings from
here about how to you know visualizing
different data types and sort of some of
the interactions that we had and we
tried to instead of focus instead of you
know not having a single Focus area to
try a different prototype which did have
a focus area so in this case you took
profit if you wanted to learn more about
profit and and figure out what was
happening and then you could visualize
profit by every any other field so in in
more of a
um a kind of a stepwise way so in this
case you see profit by state you can
change states to other you know other
options or you can start faceting that
by you know more and more fields
and adding that adding those to a thread
as well but unfortunately this is kind
of the opposite problem where you're
focusing on this on a single field on a
single field or single chart and you're
kind of losing context you're
immediately in the rabbit hole and
losing context from from everything else
so
the The Next Step from here was a
something that that tried to give the
sort of feeling of being able to explore
your data and be flexible as well as the
ability to focus in on on specific
analyzes and that's our first canvas
prototype from about May last year and
it was really at this point that we felt
that we'd gotten we really kind of
gotten somewhere and we you know we
immediately kind of saw we're able to
see new insights in in data by having
the context of the whole data set and
all the analyzes as well as something
that you know was was easily shareable
at the same time we were experimenting
with other approaches to you know
enhance this so an example is this GPT
experiment now we found very early on
which is the same thing so many people
did at that point was that generate
using llms to generate code was pretty
fraught but using it to generate
metadata things which is stuff that's
pretty useful but people don't usually
bother with because of the friction it
actually worked really well so here
we're generating you know potential
descriptions for this data set
and then we took what we we built we
started
we we started uh really showing it to
more and more people we've been showing
it to people through you know throughout
this this time but you know we really
kind of iterated and and and and went uh
went deep with you know potential users
and we
you know we really took the time to
craft every design detail as well so you
know for just a single little chart you
know on the point about how do you make
things with high bandwidth you know by
by really you know taking you know
taking care of the details of how every
you know piece of the product looked and
and worked
so let me
get to a demo
all right
this is what we have this is what we
have currently so
um
the empty canvas you can connect it to a
data warehouse and and and pull in data
that way what I'm going to do is just to
keep things really simple is
I'm gonna take a CSV and I'm going to
drag that onto onto the canvas so here
we have order line item data so so order
references product names and categories
and and information about each of those
each of those order line items just
going to drag that onto the canvas
so
it's uploads and processes
and we have all of the fields from that
CSV here and we've done a lot of
profiling to to to look at what you know
the statistics behind them and figure
out how to actually work with this data
that it enables us to just drag any
field that we want to look at or learn
more about onto the canvas so in this
case this is a product category you can
just drag that onto the canvas and it
creates a chart for us
it's the distribution of of product
categories across all of our orders
I mean if we want to know about sales by
product category we just grab sales and
drop it on top and because of the this
data typing system that we've built it
knows how to combine different pieces of
information and and make sensible sort
of visualizations and charts out of it
but behind the scenes it's really just
you know Primitives that we're all
familiar with it's just a table and that
table is generated by SQL and you know
so so it's it's really kind of has this
familiar feel to it as well
but there's there's a bunch of
additional interactions to really kind
of take advantage of the spatial
dimension of the canvas so for example
you can just grab the side of the chart
and gather up the very long tail of of
categories or see what's inside
or you know change the the charts into a
horizontal bar chart you can also
interact with the heading of the chart
to to reconfigure it so we can look at
the average sales by category instead or
the average you know quantity by by
category
and because we built these the
supremities underlying this it opens up
some really interesting possibilities so
for example you can grab the whole data
set and drop it onto the canvas
and gives you a bird's eye view of all
the data inside that's inside that data
set
and just like from that very first
prototype that we created you can click
to select
and any data on this anywhere on this
canvas and it highlights it everywhere
else so for example if you want to look
at what's happening you know during
these months you can just click and
highlight and and focus in on on that
information
all right
one more inter interaction with
mentioning is that you can just drop on
an additional data set so this is
something that's you know often really
difficult to do you have to if you want
to combine data from multiple different
sources we often go through data
engineering or if you if you are using
Excel or something like that you you can
you know do vlookups to to combine data
but in this case you can just drag it
onto the canvas we find the relationship
between the different data sets which
you can modify and
and it's it's it's right it's there and
connected so that you can you know look
at put all this data together so you
know to to put all this uh to you know
together you can for example take States
from these deliveries data set
and sales from the
line items data set the order data set
and see sales by state
let's actually take a look at more
States here
and then to see which which states or
What proportion of total sales across
your states have very high discounts we
just highlight the high discounts uh in
on on the the the first data set and it
shows up on on this chart so you can see
all of the that that Texas for example
Pennsylvania Florida Illinois Etc have
really like quite a lot of their sales
are you know very high driven by very
high discounts whereas that's not the
case in California New York and and
Washington
so it's very fluid and and interactive
we did a lot to try and make this like
very very responsive and I'm gonna show
you a little bit about how we did that
okay
so
making really bespoke interactions and
you know making things really performant
is not easy it's a there's quite a
trade-off between you know between that
and and and and really you know building
things fast using standard libraries low
complexity
so if we were to take a a canvas
[Music]
over here
and and and and and look at okay if we
were to just highlight on this canvas
what exactly happens
all right this is gonna show us so
you've got
um
it's really quite hard to uh to optimize
the performance of this because you you
don't have you know pre-computed
dimensions and measures it's very
flexible you can you can click and
select anywhere
um the you can click and you can click
on
unmaterialized data so for example if
you if you change a chart to sales by
day of the week There's No data set with
day of the week that's not a new column
or whatever that's just um you know
transformed and unmaterialized you can
stack up criteria to really make complex
selection criteria and you can do this
across multiple data sets
so all of these charts need to update as
quickly as possible pray for being less
than 100 milliseconds
now what is actually happening here well
what's happening is that we we need to
basically redo the queries for all of
the charts for all the tables for all
the statistics for all the fields for
all the titles for the charts
so for each of these items we need to
update the the the the queries and so
for each of these entities each of these
components on the canvas there are three
queries the Highlight condition the base
and join and the chart that comes out of
that so those will get combined into a
single query to be executed
but across all of the components we're
talking about lots and lots of queries
that are generated and then some they're
combined so we ultimately end up with at
least dozens of queries to be executed
all in parallel
and that's that's really hard to do fast
and that's just and one example of of an
interaction we also have other kind of
canvas-wide interactions like when you
convert the Highlight to a filter and
then it has to update the base data
across all the charts when you add a new
data set to a chart but we also have
interactions that are much more
localized like when I you know create
when I adjusted the size of a chart we
did all of that on the front end was at
least as much of that on the front end
as possible and then reconcile that with
the back end afterwards and then there's
you know interactions in between so
you've got all of these different types
of interactions that all have different
strategies for making them really
performant
so you know we are
um
hunch is being used by some design
Partners we really appreciate their
feedback
um if you have any feedback if you want
to try it you're welcome to you know
um yeah really really at this point
you know love talking about
what we built and how bad how we can
improve it to to better solve your uh
problems so yeah
thanks very much uh
foreign
[Music]